[Music]
you look fantastic
thank you I love this outfit can we talk
about this outfit for just a moment my
jumpsuit it's a jumpsuit jumpsuit I want
to have one for myself to wear I mean I
could I could do that for you you could
probably wear at the very long legs I'd
wear really high heels right I don't
know if men can pull that you look
absolutely gorgeous I haven't seen a
jumpsuit in a while you could pull it
off I could pull it off I'm very leggy
it'd be very a drudging this book
androgynous Rajnath oh ma hey modelesque
why are you getting the androgyny from
me I'm all man well thank you for
dressing up for the show not everyone
did
I'm here to fix the sink I mean what's
going on sometimes it's like it when
you're at the gym it's just good that
you're there well you look gorgeous as
do you let's talk about the Twilight
phenomenon the fans are so fervent about
Twilight they're so intense about it
it's is it as hard on the women in
Twilight as it is on the men of a as
crazy you know for you guys in his
intense no they're usually what happens
is the girls will run over to the female
cast members as well but then it's a lot
of questions that have nothing to do
with us
so it's all very we you do you know
Robin Taylor right could you ask Robin
Taylor to touch me breathing me look at
me can you get a lock of their hair will
they bite me a lot of questions about
the guy they bite me
oh yes that's so freaky I mean so it's
gotta be all you come away with is that
it's intense to be them obviously yes
that and I either look better on screen
or off screen who people say that team
it's why you there get like oh my gosh
there's so much prettier in person or oh
you look so different which either means
they think I look like on screen or off
screen let's be honest that's common
though I get that a lot
I get do you get that I get people that
are like no I do I get people that are
see me in person and I don't I'm
worrying about 45 layers of makeup right
now so that I show up on television but
when people see me seriously when people
see me they think oh you look so sickly
are you okay
why don't get that like some bone marrow